any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
and we are
here today
my friends jorge cham daniel whiteson
for their second book their second book
is a phenomenal book
it is called frequently asked questions
about the universe
and it's lovingly and tenderly
illustrated
by daniel i believe right daniel you're
the illustrator for all these happiness
uh yeah but i farmed it all out to jorge
that's right jorge has uh as a
coordinator i'm an outsourced
yeah
you're doing the job that daniel doesn't
want to you know big shot professor
right you know what are you gonna do
so guys i followed your meteoric rise
for many years um your story and legend
are well known after actually you were
some i think you were my first two kind
of legitimate book yes for a book
release we did a a podcast for into the
impossible way back in 2018 and you guys
were on for your first book we have no
idea
and then you came to san diego and we
did a live event with you
cliff johnson of usc
i think uh physics girl was there as
well as yours truly
and uh that was a wonderful event
and uh and i want to thank you for
returning coming back on the show and
i've been on your show and uh i do just
uh have the utmost delight whenever a
new episode of your podcast drops uh
explain the universe but today we're
going to talk about frequency frequently
asked questions facts about the universe
first question guys your first book we
have no idea why should we trust you now
yeah we should have stood ourselves up
for uh not having a sequel
although everyone joking with our sequel
should have been called we have some
ideas now
it's a great question though but you
should trust us because we're the ones
who will admit when we don't know we're
not just here to sell you on science
we're here to admit what we know and
what we don't know because for us you
know the majesty of the unknown is what
drives us our curiosity and drives all
of scientific discovery so that's what
it's all about and you know you notice
that it's frequently asked questions
about the universe not all of them
contain definitive answers that's right
and i think actually the questions are
almost more interesting and people think
of scientists like the three of us as
people who have all the answers but
actually i think it's more important
guys maybe you guys agree or not um have
questions what do you guys say to that
is it more important questions
underrated because everyone can have a
question like of those of us who have
kids no the ultimate explanation is
because i said so
are questions really so important or is
that kind of a platitude we tell our
readers and listeners
no i think questions are what uh science
is you know science is just people
asking questions i think a lot of people
out there think of sciences as like
monolithic institution that just sort of
like turns out knowledge every year but
they forget that it's a bunch of people
and science only makes progress when
some person has decided i'm going to
devote my life to this topic i want to
understand how butterflies migrate it's
important to me or i want to know how
the universe began or i want to measure
the anisotropy of the cmb
you know for example because everybody
has to make a choice and so science
moves forward because individual people
ask questions questions that are
important to them to know the answer to
and jorge you're of course scientist
engineer by training
but you also approach things in a very
visual way with your uh you know very
whimsical phd comics uh series that i've
been a fan of for for decades it feels
like now um i want to ask you do you
answer or or ever pose questions
visually does that is that even a
concept that makes sense
of course um
yeah i ask questions all the time you
know i have a notebook it's digital now
but you know it's all it's where i sort
of
outsource my my brain and where i put
all my the only questions i have and
then i have fun answering them
um but yeah i know i i do think sort of
visually which is why uh sometimes a
podcast is challenging
to think about these things um
but no yeah it's um
it's uh it's pretty interesting to sort
of think about some of these abstract
and or like grand ideas about the
universe in a sort of and try to
translate them into cartoon form that's
kind of the fun challenge for me in
these projects
i see the evolution uh both of you guys
individually but also collectively as
this uh burbaki like set that you guys
comprise um you guys have really evolved
and and branched out we were joking
before i hit record you guys have this
multimedia empire you've got
audio podcast dominating uh always top
10 science uh podcast explain the
universe you've got eleanor wonders why
just a marvelous uh resource for parents
and for for anybody who's interested in
in kind of exploring big picture things
but also yeah this this this character
eleanor so actually we didn't talk about
that last time because i don't think she
existed um talk about the evolution the
origin of eleanor and then we'll get
into this delightful new book so whoever
wants to start
yeah yeah i can chime in eleanor wonders
why it's a kids show that airs on pbs
kids it's for preschool to sort of like
first second grade and it's all about
inspiring curiosity in kids you know we
talked about how science is all about
asking questions and you know it's it's
about inspiring the little scientists
that every kid is born with you know
every kid has all this curiosity about
the world they want to know how the
world works and so they have questions
and and um unfortunately sometimes
society sometimes beats that down
eventually
uh and so we're trying to champion the
other part of it which is to encourage
kids to be curious to encourage them to
ask questions and also to kind of give
them some tools they can use to answer
their own
questions
um and so the the show the original show
was um
actually kind of independent of our book
and our podcast um you know we were sort
of in the middle of doing those projects
but then i got an email from someone at
pbs saying they were looking for new
ideas and so i wrote daniel in and we
pitched
the series and we based it on our kids
so eleanor is the name of the name of my
daughter and we also based some
characters on daniel's kids
and um and so yeah it's a big passion
project it's it's an amazing project
just because it reaches so many kids and
not just in the us but all over the
world and hopefully um brings a little
more curiosity into all of those
households
and daniel i've gotten in
trouble lately because i've been
kind of preening and saying things like
scientists who get paid by the public
like you and me
we have a moral obligation to explain
what we do to the public who pay our
salaries um but i shouldn't speak for
all scientists should i
what is your take on the obligations of
a professor as i expect when i wrote
different books and did different
projects
my department chair was like oh we won't
punish you you know we'll probably won't
punish you you know of course i had
tenure by then as you do but um
but do you feel an obligation to explain
things or or is it just something that
you're naturally talented at and
therefore you take to it but if you
didn't have that talent maybe you
wouldn't be doing it do you feel it's an
obligation and if so how do you how do
you approach that balance in your career
between teaching in the university top
university in the world and doing the
outreach that you do so spectacularly
well
uh thanks yeah
it's a lot of fun for me to do the
outreach
my view is that
academia and science it's a big field
and we have room for lots of different
kinds of folks um and there's places for
people to contribute in lots of ways you
know there are folks who are good at
outreach and they're folks who are great
at teaching and they're folks who are
great at research and they're folks who
are great at building tools and we need
all of them
i don't think everybody has to do every
part of it and that's one of the
strengths is that we can really attract
people
to do their bits you know for me
specialization is like a sign of
progress i mean i don't raise my own um
you know i don't farm my own food i'm
not my own doctor i outsource those bits
so i think it's fine if some folks like
to do it and other folks don't i
certainly wouldn't say that everybody
needs to do outreach not everybody you
know enjoys it for me it is a pleasure
and i do feel this sense that we should
make some parts of us accessible you
know
the people do pay for science and the
science is you know of the people by the
people and for the people so we do have
as an institution not as individuals an
obligation i think to come and talk to
people to explain to them why we're
doing it what we're doing and why we're
doing it why it's amazing and fun and
how they can feel a part of it
i think it's important to sort of break
down this barrier where people feel like
scientists are inaccessible
uh one of the things that i do is i hold
a public office hours where i hang out
on zoom for an hour and anybody can come
and ask physics questions and sort of
grows out of you know office hours the
university where the students can come
and they feel like they have access to
you they could ask you
about your career or they can ask you
physics questions or whatever and
there's this sense of like you know
they can hang out with you a little bit
and so i like doing public office hours
because it makes people feel like hey
there's a resource available i can go
and ask this question or i can talk to a
physicist about x y or z and people show
up and sometimes they ask for career
advice and sometimes they ask physics
questions and
i think that's that's a lot of fun um
the other question you ask is really
interesting also is how do you balance
this sort of career-wise because you
know as you say it's not something
that's always prized within academia and
i have the students now who come to uci
partially because they're into outreach
and they know that um that folks here do
it and i tell them that unfortunately
it's not something that's going to get
you a job you know if you want to be a
physics professor
having a podcast is not what's going to
get you that position
there's opportunity yeah there's
opportunity to branch out after you have
tenure um but you know the institution
is still a little weird i like the way
sean carroll says it he says you're
allowed to have hobbies as a professor
as long as they're not science hobbies
like nobody would criticize you if you
liked riding horses on the weekends but
if your hobby on the weekends is doing
science outreach then they have this
sense that it somehow diminishes your
focus on science itself
you and i know that's silly
i actually think that working on the
podcast and all these other projects
fuels my love for science it reminds me
why it's fun and exciting it taps into
that basic curiosity and interest in the
deep questions about the universe it
helps me broaden my knowledge as i like
do reading to to prepare for to talk
about some topic on the podcast uh so
for me it's been a really wonderful
experience and also you know getting to
work with artistic and creative people
like jorge who ropes me into amazing
projects i never ever would have been
involved in otherwise
yeah speaking of jorge basically the
answer brian is that every professor
should hire a cartoonist
both professions uh a lot i think
yeah although it sounds like if i recall
correct you kind of hired him you were
writing some uh stuff about the higgs
and you approached him and uh
um but yeah just to add to that i always
joke there's no one skill called
scientist
there's no one skill called uh
cartoonist right there's no one skill
called uh podcaster it's all these micro
skills and we never developed them uh
even in our scientists when we are paid
so so dearly in the state of california
to do so um uh so let's turn to the book
the book is frequently asked questions
and i thought they uh that daniel was a
bayesian that's an inside joke um but uh
but what is the most frequent of all
frequently is it asteroid dinosaur
related is it black hole related is it
uh extra dimensions and alien related
what's the most frequent of the facts of
the universe
yeah well you know i think the title is
is sort of um not just uh data and
statistically driven it's also sort of
spiritually driven you know we try to
tap into questions that
not only we get a lot on the podcast
through the podcast or through our talks
and things like that but also just
questions that you know we thought
humanity has been asking for a long time
you know big questions like where does
the universe come from or
or um you know um
why can't we go to other star and visit
other stars or can we somehow is there
another earth out there or why haven't
aliens visited us these are the
questions we cover in the book
and um yeah we just try to focus on
really sort of like existential
questions that make you sort of think
about the nature of the universe about
your role in it or whether your very
existence
in it um and also in balance we balance
that with questions we with real
questions we get from uh listeners
yeah that's right and and as we say near
the end of the book maybe the most
frequently asked question is the one
that comes second like people ask us a
question about some physics and then
they ask us what does it mean
you know like all right so we have this
theory about how the universe started
what does that mean about the universe
or about my life or what does that tell
me and i think that's really fun because
it connects to the the bridge between
physics and philosophy you know that
physics the things we learn about the
universe from physics can tell us
things about how to live our lives and
what it means and so
for me maybe the the most frequently
asked question is that implicit one
there's like what does it mean the
universe is this way and not the other
way
what does it mean man
that matters that we do there is one
question we covered in a book that we do
seem to get a lot and that it's one
about black holes
there's a chapter in the book about
instead of like a beat by beat of what
happens if you fall into a black hole
what are you going to experience are you
actually going to die can you survive
going into the black hole
um
and and so for some reason people seem
to be really curious about black holes
and
probably because we don't know what's in
them yeah exactly
right we always get uh get the questions
about the things that are mysterious to
everybody i always like questions that
start off with you know this is a simple
question but you know what happens if
you shrank the plank scale by a factor
of uh so let's talk about uh black holes
i love this this chapter you know what
happens if i get sucked into a black
hole and you know partially because it's
it's it's familiar but it's also kind of
you know dastardly remote i mean nobody
knows what happens ultimately and i
think a lot of the questions are
answered by that
and that's what's so exciting about
science like you know i always say you
know you never win science you know
science is not a finite game like chess
it's it's there are finite games within
it like uh getting into grad school uh
getting the tenure track position
winning the nobel prize those are all
you know zero-sum games or finite
so-called finite games but science isn't
and so of course there's going to be
things that we don't know and the arch
of john ultra wheeler once said you know
science is like expanding this island
the size of an island
and as you do so the ocean of ignorance
gets smaller but the boundary between
them also grows so this question i get a
lot and actually i've asked that not
necessarily mr roger penrose or reinhard
gensel when they're on my show but uh
but i want to ask you guys uh
the fact that we don't know exactly what
happens has been troubling me and many
people
so let me last get a you know maybe an
expert question
because we often hear that we need a
quantum theory of gravity to understand
a black hole singularity
can we ever know without such a thing in
other words is it really a two-part
question that you know
what is the ultimate you know
quantization of gravity or is that even
possible and then we can ask what
happens if you go inside a black hole so
either one of you guys
i think that's a question yeah that's
jorge let's take it off of course yeah
but i'll defer to daniel on this one you
know i think i can't answer it just from
having recorded 300 episodes of our
podcast together
well it's a really fun question because
it sort of goes to the balance between
experimental and theoretical physics
right like can you figure this stuff out
before you see it or do you need to see
it in order to understand and the thing
that's fascinating for me about the
black holes is that we sort of do know
what's in them what's in them are the
secrets to quantum gravity like if you
could go inside a black hole and observe
what's going on in there is there a
singularity is there some quantum
fuzziness that would tell you a lot of
what you needed to know presumably to
build a quantum theory of gravity
um and and so that's sort of like what
we need and the thing that's wonderful
about the universe and the reason that
i'm an experimentalist and not a
theorist is that some of these things
just have to be discovered you can't
just sit in the cave somewhere and think
your way through the puzzle of the
universe you have to go out and explore
because the universe is constantly
confronting us with things we never
imagined which take us a hundred years
to come to deal to terms with you know
like is it really that way what are you
sure
and then finally you know 100 years
later undergrads are like oh of course
you know it takes a while and so i think
you have to go out into and to explore
sometimes to discover these things now
of course it's possible
that somebody out there has a theory of
quantum gravity or will develop one
which later we proved to be correct but
i think it's much more likely that some
weird discovery we make some something
which violates general relativity maybe
on the micro scale you know these
experiments with like small um quantum
entangled gravitationally interacting
particles maybe will give us a sense for
the direction of quantum gravity but i
think it's the experiments that need to
lead the way because i suspect the
universe is weirder than even theorists
can imagine
and jorge i actually do
find it kind of curious to know if you
were inspired in any way by a great
cartoonist by the name of sir roger
penrose
who did tremendous work some say he won
his nobel prize for a single diagram
in a 1964 paper on the you know
space-time properties of black holes um
he of course draws all sorts of
whimsical shapes and so forth
and and maybe that's connected to this
concept of discovery that we mentioned
earlier but um but are there you know
places in physics that lend themselves
more naturally to artistic uh depiction
yeah well it's kind of tricky because
you know if um if we sort of know what
it looks like then it's easy to draw but
then you don't get to use your
imagination as much
whereas if we don't know what it looks
like um then you know i'm sort of free
to imagine what or interpret that or
come up with interesting ways to depict
it but then you know it's like who knows
who knows if i'm if i'm right or not
um i would say sort of the hardest thing
i always find hard to draw is a quantum
just the idea of quantum physics and
things like the fuzziness of of
particles or the you know orbitals
around
the nucleus of an atom you know those
are things that maybe a two-dimensional
uh black and white drawing are kind of
difficult to really capture
but yeah no i agree everyone who draws
cartoons is a genius for sure
uh and so for both of you guys in the
zeitgeist in the spirit of the times uh
this will be out after uh after
halloween unfortunately but uh but the
ghost of the times the spirit of the
times uh have been aliens not just
aliens
uh that is covered in
in facts about the universe um what does
that kind of reveal more is it more of a
scientific question
is it a sociological question is it an
escapist question you know that uh david
kaiser when he was on the show
discussing his book quantum legacies
talked about you know this confluence of
of the nuclear age and the information
age and that led to you know sightings
and thoughts about extraterrestrials etc
etc what do you make of this uh lately
either one of you or both of you um
and there's this notion that you know we
are being visited potentially by an
extraterrestrial uh intelligence of some
kind and there are events that we can't
explain
and i guess the question is where does
the boundary of like saying well we have
no idea you know
we leave off and say well there are some
ideas that actually we have some idea
but not not a great idea so maybe daniel
first uh what do you make of this first
of all this popularity of the notion of
ufos in the public and then
maybe
jorge what do you do with this like do
you
how do you address it in a way that's
respectful but also takes it seriously
yeah it's a lot of fun and i'm always
saying on the podcast i'm looking
forward to the alien invasion because in
that brief moment before they eat us or
zap us maybe they'll share with us their
theory of quantum gravity and you know
that'll make it all worth it
and so i read these reports with
enthusiasm i'm like oh yay maybe the
aliens have come i mean i think people
on the podcast hear me being skeptical
but i'm skeptical but i'm also
optimistic you know i'm open-minded i
definitely want this to happen
i want to believe
um but it's hard to look at frankly any
of these events these navy pilot reports
or the videos and take much away from
them that's sort of concrete if you put
your skeptic's hat on
we actually had mick west on our podcast
and we went through a lot of these
videos sort of frame by frame and broke
them down and a lot of them frankly have
prosaic explanations you know you can
understand why this looks this way
because of lens flare or this one is you
know sort of a forced perspective or and
you know none of this is conclusive but
if there are simple explanations for
these things um then it's hard to come
away with inclusion that there's
something going on we don't understand
um
unfortunately you know and uh a bunch of
people wrote in after that episode it
was like how could you have somebody
like mick west on your program he's
anti-alien
you know and i don't think he's
anti-alien i think he's just he's
looking for a
for an explanation that's reasonable and
it's simple and that's what we have to
do uh before we conclude that something
is extraterrestrial or alien then we
have to um you know we have to dismiss
all other possibilities we have to
assess them at least and i think that
this question about aliens really breaks
into two one is like people seeing weird
stuff out their windows or things you
can't explain these sort of ufo
phenomena but i think there's a much
more serious and exciting
understanding in the last 20 or 30 years
that the universe is filled with
habitable planets and that makes the
prospect that there really are
extraterrestrials out there maybe not
here on earth but out there in the
universe much more scientifically
responsible to imagine and so i think
that maybe drives it you know maybe
there's a coupling between like the
legitimate scientific exploration of the
question of extraterrestrial
intelligence out there and people's
excitement for things they see uh you
know the weird videos and the things
they see out their windows
yeah and using it as a as an opportunity
to explain legitimate as you say
scientific questions and i agree i had
on
mick as well and i actually had on
people from the jason's a super secret
society
um they're all like yeah hell this would
be great i'd love to you know learn uh
you know to win the next 80 nobel prizes
in a row or something
but uh but yeah in the same token we
have to be careful and think about well
is this really data who does it belong
to you know what are eyewitness accounts
you know how are they reliable if we all
had a courtroom sketch artist like jorge
around at all times of course everything
would be documented perfectly
another thing that you know maybe ties
into that is this notion of another
earth and this had some really lovely uh
ideas and and depictions and you know
hey was there a chapter that was the
most fun for you to to kind of
illustrate and contribute to or are they
all like your children children uh
singular uh that they're all your
favorite
yeah i don't have as many kids as you
have brian but uh i do love all of my
drawings
they're all special
in their own special way yes um
no they're all good they're all fun to
draw i mean that one about another earth
was particularly fun just because we had
a lot of fun kind of thinking about this
question like is there another planet we
could live in in somewhere else and what
would that mean what would they look
like until there's there's a lot of fun
cartoons about like
a rocky planet and sort of dressed like
a rock star or
you know instead of thinking of
another planet as like a home remodeling
project and what that would take
and whether or like sort of like going
home shopping and and um
what sort of things would you want to
look for when shopping for a new home
for your species or your
entire civilization um so yeah that one
was fun to grab
and maybe i could just step in and sing
jorge's praises for a moment here
because you know one of the reasons that
this book contains cartoons is that some
things are difficult to describe with
words you really need something visual
and often when we when i was writing
first draft of this i would think but
this is tricky
i'm sure jorge can sort this out with a
nice cartoon and then it comes back to
me with this amazing depiction that
really like crystallizes the ideas and
shows you how things connect or you know
pokes fun it did something at the heart
of it
so i really love all the all the
drawings that he put in there because it
really it's not just there for comic
relief and to break up the pages they
really contribute to the essential
science communication and making it um
understandable
and dovetailing from there into uh
briefly into eleanor wonders why for a
second how do you come up with topics or
are they handed to you by the network
bigwigs you know you you have to cover
you know the simulation hypothesis which
we'll get to in a bit uh you know
whatever
how do you come up with ideas for for
the series
for the tv
network overlords are pbs so they don't
wear big wigs they're very humble people
and very nice they wear medium-sized
wigs
well for that show we really started
from what we thought questions kids
might ask
and because there's lots of things
adults like to talk about science they
get excited about xyz but we really
wanted to make sure that every episode
was answering a kid's question
and you know jorge has kids in the and
the show is named after his daughter who
asks lots of questions and you have kids
and i have kids and we spend time around
kids so we know the kids come at these
things with a different set of
preconceptions and they ask questions
which are amazing or interesting and so
we sort of put on our three-year-old
goggles and just just walked around the
neighborhood or the world and looked at
and said like what questions would kids
ask
and so every episode
starts with a real question we think a
kid can ask and sometimes questions our
kids asked us or you know a neighbor kid
asked me one day and i was like ooh
that's a good one um you know why do
spider webs have holes in them for
example you know
stuff like this
yeah very good yeah and you know
what we can do daniel and i uh sort of
uh lasted us for about 40 episodes but
we still had needed 40 more and so we
were thankful to have just a great team
of writers you know these shows have
like a writing stat a writing team and
you know we try to tap people who were
not normal um
writers and people who were you know
lifetime children's writers and everyone
came in with uh just really great and
fun ideas about
just again like what what what does the
world look like to little kids and how
can we kind of inspire them to to
explore
another topic that's kind of again in
the in the public mind or is the
so-called simulation hypothesis i love
that chapter in the book are we in this
living in a simulation
it's you know some of these are just not
falsifiable so how do you approach a
subject like that um you know maybe
daniel first
what is the simulation hypothesis for
those that might not be familiar and
then you know jorge how could you even
depict such a thing and the way that you
did or what inspired you
to
provide this kind of really uh fleshing
out the as we would say the complete
vector space of of all these different
possibilities of something that's
admittedly both extremely complex to
even describe but also to
uh to be verified or you know to
approach using the finite tools of the
scientific method so so daniel what is a
simulation hypothesis and and then jorge
how did you choose to approach it
simulation hypothesis is something
people are probably familiar with by now
it's this idea that perhaps our lives
are not real the universe is not
physical that we live inside a
simulation in a computer in some other
sort of like super meta universe
and you know it's not unusual or weird
to think about writing a simulation in a
computer we do it all the time in
science we say what would happen if
these two galaxies collided and we write
a little computer program that simulates
it that gives us the answer and so you
might imagine that if you had a
simulation that was complex enough that
it could have like you know
life emerge inside of it an intelligent
life that those beings that lived inside
that simulation in your computer might
not be aware of the fact that they're
inside a simulation how would they know
and so that you know you flip that
around and you say well maybe our
universe is a simulation from some very
incredible high performance computer in
some other universe
and you're right that it's not
necessarily something we can verify
though in the book we talk about you
know ways you might be able to figure
out you're in a simulation looking for
bugs or computational limitations etc um
but you know science isn't limited to
things we can necessarily falsify
there's lots of theories
of science and how it can proceed
a lot of folks focus on things that are
experimentally falsifiable
but you know it's also possible to make
arguments like if you could come up with
a theory of the universe that was the
only one that's consistent with our data
and it has implications for things that
you cannot measure then you could you
could conclude that those things are
probably real
so i don't think that you necessarily
need to be able to experimentally
interact with things in order to have a
strong argument that they're real though
of course as an experimentalist i always
want to have the hard truth the data i
want to go see it or touch it or send a
probe out there so it'd be pretty cool
to get to interact with the masters of
the universe if you do live in a
simulation
and of course you know i think today uh
mark zuckerberg announced the metaverse
or something like that uh jorge how do
you approach you know depicting things
that you know may or may not it may or
may not be legitimate to demand that
they're falsifiable or not but but yet
that's a common refrain um you know all
the more so when it could be you who's
being simulated uh drawing the
simulation and so we could get really
meta uh on this and ask you know who's
simulating the simulators uh is that the
coast guard's job who does that but
anyway uh jorge how do you depict
something which for which we have zero
evidence at least at
present yeah yeah maybe we're all npcs
you know non-physics characters
really um no yeah this is my favorite
kind of question to tackle in the book
just because it is so wild and so
potentially
unfalsifiable and so
kind of out there to to draw
and you know i think our general
approach was to tackle these kinds of
questions
in a way that not just kind of get to
nest but also kind of demonstrate a
little bit how physics and scientists
and engineers would sort of tackle these
big questions you know we asked the
question also in the book is an
afterlife possible and usually that's
you know sort of a ticking time bomb
in science
and religion and things like that but
you know we try to show kind of like
well how would a scientist approach this
like let's break it down like well what
exactly do you mean by simulation and
how would that even
what would that mean and how would that
what are some of the different ways that
that could happen and what are some of
what would be some of the implications
for that and
and um and um
and like um and like you know what are
some of the ways in which you could
maybe potentially demonstrate whether or
not that's true or not
and um and so yeah i had a lot of fun
drawing a little brains and bats i think
that's the go to a little brain hooked
up to playstation 4 is sort of the go-to
um depiction of a simulated world
and then they're you know in contra
distinction to those or contrast of
those their book there are chapters in
this delightful book
frequently asked questions about the
universe of course it could have been
the multiverse you talk about other
universes so i think you show a
pro-universe bias that i find not only i
but andre linde has made a claim that
you should not be prejudiced to think of
it as a universe first you should think
of it as a multiverse so anyway next
book titled actually
actually that was a dinner time question
my daughter eleanor asked me one day out
of the blue i mean i think she was like
six or seven and she's like
how can there be multiple universes
wouldn't they all just be the universe
yeah i was like
you got you got you you've got all
physics right when we were kids
that's all there was
that's the problem but that actually
brings out something interesting that
you know when i when i was reading this
book like the caliber of the question
some of them are for care you know kid
level you know there's one when will the
sun burn out okay that has a very you
know specific scientific uh rationale
that we can approach and answer
definitively unlike you know we have no
idea you know see our first book buy our
first book
no you guys don't do that as i would
shamelessly do but um
but you know some of the questions that
are asked at least by you know and
eleanor and other um uh work that you
guys do
uh it is a lot higher than what we would
have asked right and you know as as kids
just like 30 years ago 40 years ago um
we're all approximately to a physicist
the same age i'm probably the oldest one
but but anyway the looking back at you
know cal like when i was a kid i
wouldn't ask you know what about the
multiverse or the simulation i bought
and now our kids are asking such
questions um you know and the the
appropriate response is you know go to
bed or do your homework
what do you think that's nice
though do you think that like science is
inevitably going to lead to smarter and
smarter children
you know if the matrix doesn't you know
isn't caused by a future advanced
civilization it could be a civilization
that's currently living among us namely
our kids so the caliber of questions of
our kids are really getting much more
sophisticated wouldn't you say
absolutely but i think that's progress
you know i think things that were
cutting edge controversial ideas a
hundred years ago now we can teach them
to five-year-olds yeah and i think
that's wonderful
i know that for example if i was able to
get into a time machine and go to the
year 3000 i wouldn't go to a physics
conference because there's no way i'd
figure it out i'd go to like the
children's section of the library and
i'd start reading astronomy books and
cosmology books for five-year-olds
because that's the only thing i'd ever
had a chance to even understand
and so i think that just shows the sort
of you know slow rolling nature of
scientific progress that the basic idea
is that our basic view of the universe
has changed and so now what we teach to
children and therefore the questions
they ask are also changing i think
that's pretty awesome
um and so the last topic before we turn
i want to spend some time talking about
your podcast and and um getting some
ideas that i can poach to grow my
podcast for me guys uh but uh is this
notion of why i was always taught that
why it's not a scientific question you
know why is there this it's some
teleological method you know motivation
of intent which you can ascribe to the
blind tittie-less indifference of the
universe's uh inexorable evolution what
do you guys say the last chapter talks
about why you know it is a why question
i don't like to give away the book and
you know i want people to buy every
single version of this book
possible so
are why questions are they not taboo
guys and and why do you end with a y if
i can ask a double double why
yeah well we're all our kids just call
eleanor wonders why and so if that's
that's not allowed then we're in trouble
but yeah you know i know that there's
something sort of a traditional line
between philosophy and physics but um
you know i never saw a why question as
as being particularly taboo you know you
can ask like why is the sky blue and
that definitely has an answer
um
you know you can definitely give a
physical answer to that right
sure yeah and sometimes we confuse you
know why with how or what um i do
remember a saying of einstein
where he
attributed his curiosity later on in
life to the fact that he never asked
certain questions as a kid in fact he he
credited the sophistication
uh with which he approached questions as
a 25 year old patent clerk uh to the
fact that he never asked these ques like
he made explicit mention that i never
asked my dad
what happened if i traveled alongside a
light beam and looked at myself in the
mirror you know or you know tried to
send a tick tock you know
but but you know he said because if i
did you know my dad would have given me
the best answer of the time which was
wrong because he had to wait until he
himself came about um so i you know i
think that that um you know as much as
we do want to you know kind of inculcate
this notion of curiosity amongst
kids etc we also have to you know
recognize that sometimes the
sophistication of the answer
can't be really appreciated until one is
much much more developed and it's not a
knock it's just that's just you know
it's like you can't paint a masterpiece
you know straight out of kindergarten
so finding that balance i think is is
sort of crucial and maybe this dovetails
a little bit into into the podcast now
because you you kind of blend a melange
of styles and you know sometimes you
have guests sometimes too you guys
riffing and and um how do you approach
it how do you approach different topics
is it is it just you know what people
you know send in or is it stuff that
you're really curious about or guests
like mick west you talked about or you
know you're your most uh you know
impressive guest to date yours truly uh
but tell me what what is your strategy
there is it is it one of like i'm
interested in this let's find it out or
is it like
how do you balance appealing to what the
audience wants versus what you guys want
uh yeah a great question uh first let me
chime in on the previous one about
physics and philosophy yeah um i think
that you're right that often physics
tries to stay separate from philosophy
that a lot of physicists um is jew you
know talking about philosophy
um i think that's silly i think that
there's not a crisp and clear line
between the two i think that a lot of
the questions we ask in physics have
philosophical motivations and the the
answers we get from physics have
philosophical consequences
and even the people who say like you
know philosophy is a waste of time they
don't realize you know that's a
philosophical position uh they're in
effect doing philosophy without even you
know really thinking about it carefully
so i would say that why questions are
vital the why questions fuel the how
questions and how answers inform the why
questions so i think it's it's all a
wonderful mixture
here at uci we have a lot of folks who
do really interesting
philosophy of science and i'm often over
at their seminars asking the naive
physicist questions
um
but to your point about the podcast um i
think that we do all of that we
sometimes do questions that where i
think this is something will blow
people's minds and is not widely
appreciated or i haven't seen talked
about in an accessible way before that i
think people will find really really
cool you know for example we recently
had an episode on the wimp miracle and a
lot of people are interested in dark
matter but there's not a lot of like
accessible discussion out there for why
science coalesced around this idea of
dark matter as a particle and in large
part it was because of this whimp
miracle this you know um suggestion that
maybe dark matter was this weekly
interacting massive particle
and so we talk about that and a lot of
questions a lot of topics come from
listeners they write to us and they ask
us hey can you explain this or they say
i need a daniel and jorge treatment of
this they send me an article they're
like i didn't get it what's going on can
you break this down
um and so we have a big mixture of stuff
whatever people find fun and we explore
different topics sometimes we interview
science fiction authors about the
universes they build in their books and
the physics of it which i think is a lot
of fun also
and then you also take questions from
listeners right if people send in
questions and sometimes we not just
devote episodes to answering questions
but also
they inspire topics to cover right yeah
absolutely yeah people can write to us
with any question to questions at
danieljorge.com
we actually answer every single email
usually within a day or so and some of
the really good questions yeah we talk
about them on the podcast a whole
episode
can be devoted to that or sometimes
people send in an audio of themselves
asking questions and they have a whole
episode just answering listener
questions uh which is really fun and and
i'm you know try really hard to engage
with the audience and make them feel
like they're a part of this process it's
like a conversation not just a one
directional podcast from us to them
and maybe daniel to wrap up i want to
get your impression of there's been a
lot of uh recent particle physics
results and you are of course one of the
preeminent experimental particle
physicists in the world and um doing
yeoman's work from everything from
working on
lhc work uh two uh to your crayfish io
which i'd love to hear about again uh in
person next time you come and give a
colloquium here um been a lot of results
g minus two
there's been the lhcb
results actually a couple of them
just yesterday we're recording this on
the 29th
28th of october and just yesterday there
were results from microboone
claiming on one hand you know
consistency with the standard model on
the other hand a whole new chapter of
physics has been opened up and
um
you know what
what's going on here are there really
you know fifth forces and physics beyond
the standard model or is that just what
you know big particle physics has to do
in order to get bread buttered
be honest all right are we seeing
everything up fight here am i seeing the
beginning of a fight here between uh
yeah because cosmologists never hype our
results
you're about to see a fight but it's
between two personalities i have inside
my own head there's the optimist and
there's the pessimist you know or or the
cynic the optimist says we know there's
physics beyond the standard model
there's dark matter there's neutrinos
there's all sorts of stuff that we just
cannot describe with the standard model
we know it's not everything
on the other hand the cynic says i don't
really think that anything we've seen is
very exciting or persuasive i really am
kind of a cynic when it comes to these
discoveries because they tend to come
and go and people get really excited
about them and then they fade away
um
often you know and so you know let's
talk about the individual ones you
talked about
the lhcb measurement and this is a
measurement of you know whether
particles talk to electrons and muons at
the same level muons are like the heavy
cousins of electrons and we think it's
important in our theory that these
particles interact with electrons and
muons and also taus at the same level
and lhcb sees this evidence that maybe
they don't but if you add up all the
numbers they see some hints but it's not
really very conclusive it's like it's a
tantalizing hint because we want to find
something and we look in lots and lots
of places so if you do that then
eventually you're going to find
something weird it's like if you set a
thousand monkeys to flip a coin 100
times some of them are going to give you
weird results you know pretty far from
the distribution of 50 50. and so that's
sort of the situation we're desperate to
find something new and we're hunting for
tantalizing new effects
the mu1 g minus 2 is also interesting um
because you know what they saw there
doesn't agree with the theoretical
prediction but the theoretical
prediction also doesn't agree with other
theoretical predictions and so it's hard
to really be terribly excited about that
and the micro boone one is sort of the
most head scratching
but
my version of the story is maybe the
least exciting you know that came out of
an experiment called lsnd decades ago
that had a result that nobody understood
and frankly a lot of people were
skeptical of they thought
maybe they didn't understand something
and then they did a follow-up experiment
to try to understand it called mini boon
and mini boone saw something else weird
that they didn't understand that wasn't
consistent with lsmt and i remember
thinking at the time well it's the same
folks
maybe
you know maybe we they don't understand
the backgrounds they expect in that
experiment
and now micro boone has come out and
basically said no to the favorite theory
that could describe lsnd and mini boon
and to me that just says well the most
likely explanation is that those
experimentalists you know got it wrong
they didn't understand their backgrounds
as well as they thought they did not
that there's some new chapter of physics
so i'm really kind of a cynic when it
comes to you know declaring that one of
these one of these discoveries is really
heralding some new physics i really got
to see a lot more data before i get
excited about it
i think i think that harkens back maybe
even to your first book we have no idea
uh sometimes you get you know spend
millions of dollars and decades of your
life and you get what's called a null
result then you get something that's
just not you know inconsistent with what
came before and those are important they
don't usually happen to make the front
page of the uh oc register the pasadena
star news
these are all you know like a rock
concert now i've always said my city's
name no uh or the san diego union
tribune i can't i can't neglect the
paper of record um but you know this is
this is
it's always interesting to have this
rubric and i think you guys do it oh so
well what we can understand what we
can't um what we can potentially not
understand and everything in between and
giving people permission to ask these
questions and to have legitimate um
serious answers and i think that is very
commendable um and i want to give uh
give maybe just the last word to jorge
what is going on with phd comics
sometimes i see it's it's it's it's like
regular it's coming out something oh
there's a new comic i just saw i
retweeted one i was like this is like
ripped from today's headlines and it's
from 2010. what's going on with phd
comics yeah a great question um i don't
know
is the quest the answer
uh you know i did it for like 20 20 15
years and
and then all these amazing other fun
projects came in you know making movies
based on the comics um starting a
youtube animation um collaborative and
then the book with daniel on the podcast
and the tv show and
and so um you know thank you to all my
fans for being patient but um but you
know in these days i sort of
just kind of when i find the time
instead of or when i feel inspired and
uh is when i'll post a new one or um you
know even like posting old comics is
sort of a lot of work and so you know
sometimes i'll get inspired and really
want to connect with people and so i'll
i'll start posting again but um
yeah yeah there's just too much fun work
to do that's right to too short the life
as you're in
blair brighter carlo rovelli always says
the life is just too short but you guys
are making a huge dent in the multiverse
with this latest contribution to the
scientific ubra
frequently asked questions about the
universe all right cham daniel whiteson
uh so my original two guests um actually
last time you were together and i had to
like virtually pull you apart you know
you guys were just that no but
you guys have such a great chemistry um
uh it's it's it's it's always a delight
when when a book comes out but it's it's
a it's a delight when every one of your
podcast episodes and eleanor uh asks
wonders why um you guys keep doing what
you're doing it's so vital it's so uh
commendable and i just want to
congratulate you guys um you guys are
the real deal you set the standard for
other podcasters and science
communicators to aspire to so i want to
thank you guys so much and wish you the
greatest of success with this wonderful
book and promise me you'll come back uh
on the podcast again and again um
if only to just discuss the latest
weather because it's always a
fascinating time to be with you guys
yeah why is it why is it hot or is that
not a question we're supposed to ask
southern california it's uh
not atypical thank you guys and best of
luck with this wonderful new book
yeah thank you brian
all those things seem to you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
you